kaito grows tomatoes in two separate
fields when the tomatoes are ready to be
picked he is curious as to whether the
sizes of his tomato plants differ
between the two fields he takes a random
sample of plants from each field and
measure the and measures the heights of
the plants
here is a summary of the results
so what i want you to do is pause this
video and conduct a two sample t test
here and let's assume that all of the
conditions for
inference are met the random condition
the normal condition and the
independence condition and let's assume
that we are working with a significance
level of 0.05
so can pause the video and conduct the
two sample t test here to see whether
there's evidence that the sizes of
tomato plants differ between the fields
all right now let's work through this
together so like always let's first
construct our null hypothesis and that's
going to be the situation where there is
no difference between the mean sizes so
that would be that the mean size in
field a is equal to the mean size in
field b
now what about our alternative
hypothesis
well he wants to see whether the sizes
of his tomato plants differ between the
two fields he's not saying whether a is
bigger than b or whether b is bigger
than a and so his alternative hypothesis
would be around his suspicion that the
mean of a is not equal to the mean of b
that they differ
and to do this two sample t test now we
assume the null hypothesis
we assume
our null hypothesis and remember we're
assuming that all of our conditions for
inference are met and then we want to
calculate a t statistic based on this
sample data that we have and our t
statistic
is going to be equal to the differences
between the sample means
all of that over our estimate of the
standard deviation of the sampling
distribution of the difference of the
sample means
this will be the sample standard
deviation from sample a squared
over the sample size from a
plus the sample standard deviation from
the b sample squared over the sample
size from b
and let's see we have all the numbers
here to calculate it this numerator is
going to be equal to
1.3 minus 1.6 1.3 minus 1.6
all of that over
the square root of let's see the
standard deviation the sample standard
deviation from the sample from field a
is 0.5 if you square that you're going
to get 0.25
and then that's going to be over the
sample size from field a
over 22
plus 0.3 squared so that is 0.3 squared
is 0.
all of that over the sample size from
field b all that over 24.
the numerator is just going to be
negative 0.3
divided by
the square root of .25
divided by 22
plus
.09
divided by 24
and that gets us
negative 2.44
approximately negative 2.44
and so if you think about a t
distribution
and we'll use our calculator to figure
out this probability so this is a
t-distribution right over here
this would be the assumed mean of our
t-distribution and so we got a result
that is negative we get a t statistic of
negative 2.44 so we're right over here
so this is
negative 2.44
and so we want to say what is the
probability from this t distribution of
getting something at least this extreme
so it would be
this area and it would also be and it
would also be this area if we got 2.44
above the mean it would also be this
area
and so what i could do is i'm going to
use my calculator to figure out this
probability right over here and then i'm
just going to multiply that by 2 to get
this one as well
so the probability
of getting
a
t value i guess i could say where it's
absolute value is greater than or equal
to 2.44
is going to be approximately equal to
i'm going to go to second
distribution i'm going to go to the
cumulative distribution function for our
t distribution
click that
and since i want to think about
this
tail probability here and then i'm just
going to multiply by 2. the lower bound
is a very very very negative number you
could view that as functionally negative
infinity
the upper bound is negative 2.44
negative 2.44
and now what's our degrees of freedom
well if we take the conservative
approach it'll be the smaller of the two
samples minus one
well the smaller of the two samples is
22 and so 22 minus 1 is 21.
so put 21 in there
and now
i can paste
and i get
that number right over there and if i
multiply that by 2 because this just
gives me the probability of getting
something lower than that but i also
want to think about the probability of
getting something 2.44 or more above the
mean of our t distribution so times 2
is going to be equal to approximately
0.024
so approximately
and what i want to do then is compare
this to my significance level and you
can see very clearly this right over
here this is equal to our p-value
our p-value in this situation
our p-value in this situation is clearly
less than our significance level
and because of that we said hey assuming
the null hypothesis is true we got
something that's a pretty low
probability below our threshold so we
are going to reject
reject our null hypothesis which tells
us that there is so this suggests
this suggests
the alternative hypothesis that there is
indeed a difference between the sizes of
the tomato plants in the two fields